brossant main cette coiffeuse refuse de
fermer boutique
sabine fleurette travaillent dans
l'illégalité depuis l'instauration du
rpt confinement au risque de se faire
verbaliser par les forces de l'ordre
je trouve c'est injuste qu'on soit fermé
parce qu'on a mis tout en oeuvre pour
recevoir la clientèle de bonnes
conditions
moi je travaille seul donc les gens sont
seuls avec moi voyez il ya quand même
beaucoup moins de risques que dans
l'écran ans pour la soutenir elle peut
compter sur la mairesse de dell sandrine
larcher a pris un arrêté municipal lundi
matin pour autoriser la réouverture des
commerces se considérait comme non
essentiels dans sa commune une mesure
symbolique pour faire entendre la voix
du monde rural
oublié par le gouvernement selon elle
aujourd'hui on veut gérer toute la
france
à l'échelle de paris la ville de delle
là on est chez un commerçant qui qui
reçoit huit clients dans une journée ça
n'a rien à voir avec un salon parisien
c'est ça que je dénonce lui aussi a fait
de la protection des commerçants sa
priorité à audincourt martial bourquin
est le premier maire avoir pris un
arrêté municipal vendredi dernier il
condamne 1re confinement incohérent
entre grandes surfaces parfois vendée et
boutiques de proximité dans l'obligation
de tirer le rideau
je ne comprends pas que dans les arrêtés
ministériels
on n'est pas voulu faire en sorte que
des petits commerces qui pratique des
règles sanitaires très drastiques
soit ouvert au moins sur rendez vous si
aucun commerce non essentiels de la
ville n'a ouvert ce matin
la gérante de cette maroquinerie à
braver l'interdiction quelques heures ce
week end
emilie loit show se lance désormais dans
la commande en ligne
faute de mieux c'est limité la casse
parce que on ne peut pas même avec le
click and collect arriver au chiffre que
nous faisons d'habitude avec une
clientèle qui rentrent en boutique
les deux maires ont rendez vous ce jeudi
au tribunal administratif de besançon à
la suite de leur arrêté
l'issue ne fait guère de doute il
devrait être retoquée